JIMMY TRAN: Did you
hear Yanny or Laurel?
I heard Yanny.
This would be a
great opportunity
to use the Google
Cloud Speech API to see
if your suspicions are correct.
The Speech API allows you to
send audio and receive a text
transcription from the
speech-to-text API service.
Learning how to use
this API is easier
than you might have thought.
In fact, you can
learn how to use it
in about 15 minutes in Qwiklabs.
And no, you do not need
a Google Cloud Platform
account or project to
try this for yourself.
An account, project,
and associated resources
are provided to you as
part of the Qwiklab.
In this lab, you'll create
a file for the request
to the Speech API.
You'll then see the
transcript value
return the Speech API's
text transcription
of your audio file.
The confidence value
indicates how sure
the API is that it's accurately
transcribed your audio.
And just like that, you've
created a Speech API request.
The Speech API supports both
synchronous and asynchronous
speech-to-text transcription.
In this example, you sent
it a complete audio file.
But you can also use the
sync recognize method
to perform streaming
speech-to-text transcription
while the user is
still speaking.
Qwiklabs is an online hands-on
lab library available 24 hours
a day, seven days a week
with more than 150 labs
on every cloud topic from
intro to expert level.
Each lab helps you learn a
new skill in about 30 minutes
using Google Cloud.
When you're ready, use this
link to take the lab we just
went through today.
And when you're ready
to sign up for GCP,
use this link to apply a
$300 credit to your account.
We want to hear from you.
Every week we'll answer a
question from our viewers.
So let us know what's on your
mind in the comments below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]